okay so next up we have lightning talks
uh they're going to be very fast and
there's a lot of bright people who put
their titles
um to sign up for lighting talks but
apparently they didn't put their names
uh so if you see your title if I call it
please come up and sit on uh these two
empty seats are up here and
oh no
hey everyone so as mentioned just said
we are going to be doing lightning talks
in this room so don't go anywhere all
right lightning talks they're starting
right here
right now
um
all right so the first lightning talk we
have for today Trump's Twitter tirada
and next up we have null what is null
so if the title of your talk is no what
is null please come sit up awesome all
right Trump's Twitter tirata can I have
your name Peter all right guys we have
Peter up here for Tom's Twitter tirada
put your hands together
[Applause]
[Music]
this works
okay thank you yeah perfect perfect
I'll try
yep all right so the way this works is
every talk has a five minute time limit
and we have a one minute remaining
marker so which will show to the uh
speaker and at the end of the five
minutes we're going to start clapping no
matter how interesting the talk is or
who it is
all right
yeah
thank you
am I on
okay hey everyone so I thought I'd bring
you a relic of the past uh the former
president's tweeting habits uh so I
won't enter the Minefield of digging the
content of it just some data about uh
how he used the platform so we started
tweeting back in May 20 uh like 2009 and
then uh he definitely didn't use the
platform too much in the first two years
and yeah then in the next period things
a little bit got out of hand so uh as
you can see in the first period it was
like 36 tweets per month and then here
it was over 1100. so yeah he got quite
acquainted and then come the time when
he became a nominee so you can notice
this downward Trend I guess uh their
team his team was like telling him not
to like be more uh you know keep keep
refrain a bit and then he became
president and and that happened
so uh yeah he he really liked uh
tweeting as as you all know uh these are
all the tweets at least until uh May uh
2020 so we don't have the last period
and uh yeah and this is the number of
times these tweets were retweeted I mean
I'll go back one and and then show you
again it really tells you the story of
like uh how interesting he was perceived
by the community before he became a
nominee we call this the Trump's Twitter
trumpet uh we we don't know what this
what this bump is yet but uh if you can
help us out that I'd be very glad to see
okay so there are a couple of ways you
can see these tweets so for example see
the categories of original tweets
retweets and replies and if you see that
if you check the trends side by side he
actually like kind of forgot this reply
function of the platform right around
the time he became he became president
and uh and actually this this huge
uptake this huge surge in the number of
tweets well a majority of it comes just
from retweets towards the end of this
period and especially if you can if you
take a look at the the shares of the
tweets per month there are months there
were over 50 percent of the tweets were
just three tweets from from some from
another account okay another aspect
would be like what platform he used to
send those tweets uh first he was uh
mainly using the web interface and then
he switched to his favorite Android
phone and right around the time he
became president actually that was taken
away from him because of security
concerns and if we aggregate the number
of tweets per person it can be seen that
that iPhone is leading away with over 20
000 tweets sent just from that platform
it's already like 45
000 tweets or something in in this in
this database okay and uh the lastly we
can take a look at the time uh when when
these tweets were sent so this is a
24-hour clock with am on the right and
PM on the left and uh especially
interesting if we filter it down to
specific periods so when he was being a
businessman uh there is this like like a
search here around 3 P.M and and the the
early morning tweet Trends so we have
over 73 we have 73 tweets sent between
three and 3 15 a.m uh whereas when he
became president uh this peak is uh at
around uh like eight or nine in the
morning sorry eight and and the the
early morning or or midnight tweet rents
are gone so these were just a couple of
insights that I wanted to share with you
and there's one more thing so this whole
presentation is within a Jupiter
notebook uh did with this tool that
we're developing uh called ipivizu and
I'll be actually delivering a tutorial
of it next morning 9 A.M on the fifth
floor so come join us and we'll be
having a fun time building similar
stories but I mean you're going to be
doing most of the work I'm just saying
around and and vouching for you and if
you're interested I mean you can also
start at ipadvisor.com to get more info
and if you go to bits.li pair TTT hyphen
story or TTT hyphen notebook you can get
the notebook that I used here or just
the interactive HTML that I exported
from it thank you very much for your
attention
[Applause]
cool awesome super fast
um know what is null is up next uh
Cameron is going after this can I have
your name
Sammy's to do all right everyone give it
up for Sammy
[Music]
thank you
okay
I apologize for the wall of text uh this
is supposed to be a blog post but I'll
present this
I don't I have no idea why that's
happening
um cool
um so this is something where I think a
lot of people already know this but this
is something that was really interesting
to me and something I didn't learn until
quite recently but it's about null like
what is null and I think the the main
thing is that if you ask someone who's
like a database programmer versus
someone who's like let's say a python
programmer they would give you two very
different answers so a programmer would
probably tell you that a null is a type
of value that points to nothing or or
it's a it's a value that essentially
points a no ballot object but if you
asked a database person they would
probably tell you that Noah's a mask for
having no value
and so that's pretty interesting because
it's like in programming null is a value
but in databases it's the lack of and so
it's something that's really interesting
about that is when someone says oh it's
a null value compared when talking about
a database that's actually kind of an
oxymoron
um so because of this when we talk about
like a data frame where you're
manipulating data in a programming
language which definition should we use
and so what's some code we're going to
kind of play around with that and
actually see like what is the most
appropriate one
okay
um the next step is like talking about
like why does this matter so in Data
Systems we usually use null for whenever
we're dealing with missing data so that
could be something like the value hasn't
happened yet or it could be something
like we're doing a join a special type
of join where it has missing values or
you might do something like a fancy
aggregation like using a cube or a roll
up
okay cool let's go into an example where
we have Monty Python movies right and so
we have the title uh we have the year
and we have the review score
and in this we're just using a really
quick sqlite example where we fill in
the data so we insert these movies
um then we actually run a query and
actually see okay we want to figure out
what movies have a score that do not
equal to 7.5
and we see you know we have two movies
here and they do have scores that are
not equal to 7.5
now let's throw uh put a null in there
so we put a new movie that just came out
this year it's unreviewed because it's
new and we run the same query
SQL actually gives us uh the same result
because the result of that new movie is
null so it's not included okay now let's
do some fun let's load into pandas so
now I read the SQL query into pandas and
I print it out and I see that that null
is now a nan so it's not lack of a value
it's actually showing a marker of not a
number as that value so let's run a
query now which is let's you know find
the the movies where the scored a cycle
to 7.5 and we actually see that that new
row is actually included which is very
different than the uh SQL example we had
in sqlite
and why is this the case it's because
you know in this default behavior of
pandas we actually treat uh null as a
value rather than a marker
um so if you compare them you actually
get a Boolean value rather than
something that says no or unknown or not
valid
okay there's actually a fix to this uh
this has been around in pandas for a bit
but I feel like it's uh not commonly
known so one thing you can actually do
is when you make a panda series you can
actually give it a d-type with a capital
letter and if you do that it actually
uses a extension due type that has a bit
mask to tell you if it's Valor not valid
and so if we do this we actually see
that this value now is not a nan but a
null and it's actually has a special
marker here and when we compare stuff to
it it gives us the correct three value
logic uh if you compare to a non it is
not a nan it's not sensical and so if we
actually replace this data frame with
this new series and do the same query we
did before we actually get the correct
result
and if we did something like you know we
wanted to start the right way one thing
we could do is run the query give it a
d-type as a hint and we actually get the
correct data frame with the proper nulls
all right it's just a fun fun topic to
talk about uh thank you once again I'm
Sami I'm an author of Daft check out
getdaf.io for our framework and you know
stars are always appreciated thank you
foreign
thank you Sammy uh so we have Cameron
riddle next and after that we have
Panda's output with scikit-learn set
output API by Thomas
so I was thinking of starting my career
as a stand-up comedian today but
I don't think that's happening because I
couldn't come up with any jokes
I think I have two which I might say
later I don't know
if you laugh it's a joke if you don't
forget about it
thank you
that did not help with the blue screen
yeah very unfortunate
yeah we can try many ways but
foreign
after uh Thomas we have have you heard
of DBT uh by Burke if you're in this
room cool all right
okay
all right so we're going with Thomas
first and then Cameron after don't worry
I'll be back
foreign
two slides um
pen is upwards I can learn it's a thing
anyone heard of it
and I hear it now
um this has been long in the making
three years
um I started at three years we started
three years ago and grateful for all the
cycling maintainers that reviewed this
pull requests and spoke with me for
iterating this API for three years it's
a thing now and I'm so happy
um and I'm gonna showcase it um to you
right now
and a timer I suppose that I didn't set
but here here's the cycling API um for
um asset output it's not in the release
version yet but you could download
um on dev which I'll show you at the end
uh programming with one hand is really
hard
um uh I'll do this all right so now you
have a data frame here
all right cool with not much stuff in it
if I use standard scalar and take learn
and do nothing you get a numpy array as
you may expect but
if I call set output transforming the
pandas
something magical happens
it gives you a data frame
and better yet if you um use a pipeline
like with you're scaling it and then use
polynomial features and you saw you see
I call fit transform like I I call
transform your pandas here
like it's a data frame with like names
like that's
I can't believe this took so long but um
it did because some API design is
complicated
um
now for heterogeneous Theta um for the
Titanic data set that we all make a lot
of us learn in machine learning 101
um this is a data set with categoricals
and numerical data I have a preprocessor
here for the numerical data I have the
categorical pre-processing step for the
categorical data I have a calm
Transformer who knows about column
Transformer
now you know now it helps you handle a
panda theater frame and do different
transforms on subsets of the data
if I copy transform here you notice that
I didn't call the new hot API it gives
you a number array but
if I if I do set output
you could transform your pandas
it's
a
data frame wow
[Applause]
um but you see that there's like a
um prefixes it with the name of the
pipeline thing of the
um how I named the pre-processing step
um sometimes we do that because Justin
we don't know what names overlap but if
you know for sure that um your names
don't overlap there's a verbose option
like in this case uh the names are
verbose I could set it to false and boom
they're they're nicer names now all
right so erase the error if you of your
names over that so it's kind of nice
um with this feature you get a lot of
things if you have a predictive model
now
um um let's just regression like you
have a pre-processor with large
discretion it outputs um you see this
pipeline oh how many of you knew about
this HTML thing
that yeah I'm like this is cool like I
could click on things and like you could
see like the pipeline it's a thing it
just it outputs it by default in Jupiter
notebook now and if I call fit on this
um the classifier at the very end
remembers the feature names so so this
is classifieds religious aggression
regression is at the end it knows the
feature names that it was passed in
which means now you could connect the
coefficients of your models or however
your models are with the names and it's
all in the model so you could like make
graphs
without doing something complicated
so
um try it out it's on uh we have a we
have a um index that hosts the
the dev version of sci-fi so anyone can
install it today to try it out
um yeah that um here it's a long one
command it's one one command there
all right thanks thanks for listening
[Applause]
all right thank you Thomas so far we
haven't had anyone uh go over the time
limit which means I'm doing a great job
um Cameron is I think not here so we
will go with
have you heard of DBT
cool all right while he's coming up here
uh I realized my job was actually to
talk while they set up right so I'm not
supposed to stare at the screen along
with you guys uh that was awkward
okay yo we're still waiting um
I I could not pronounce your name sorry
poor guy
all right guys give it up for bouquet
there you go
yes all right so these are my slides
this is it have you heard of DBT it was
very quickly put together so
um
I'm burkai I'm from a company called
foul features and labels for short and
um I went around the Spy data it's my
first Pi data very exciting I went
around at asking this question have you
heard of DBT because a lot of people
that I interact with which come from
like analytics bi background work with
DBT a lot but a lot of the times I ask
this question
I heard a lot of like I haven't heard of
it or I heard about it but I don't know
what it does so I'm here to uh actually
commit the cardinal sin because this is
a sequel based tool in the in the Phi
data conference uh and and show you a
little bit about it so
um let's let's give it a shot live demo
so um
uh here's a
um the starter demo for DBT which is
called jaffle shop so it's a fictional
uh sandwich shop uh I think jaffle is
how they call Grilled Cheese in
Australia
um so um
in this fictional e-commerce store
we have some data we want to load it up
into a data warehouse like snowflake or
in this case I'm using duckdb
um and then do some Transformations on
it
um so with DBT you can get started very
easily like you can just pull this
project and then you configure your
connection uh to your data warehouse
very very easily so here I have my
profiles yaml which like stands in my
home directory and don't look at my
credentials for anything else but I I
Define my the Activity Connection right
here so it's very simple right and from
here on all I have to do is actually
write some SQL so I have my models
folder here and I just have a SQL query
um here and you know typically like what
you have to do to just get this done is
like start a connection and then like
really sequence your SQL queries and do
some orchestration to just do some uh
basic transformations in your data
warehouse what DBT helps with is like
this is all done for you so I have my
project now I can load my data with DBT
seed
and then uh so this is loading my data
and then I can do DBT docs serve
and this will serve
and show me like what my graph my SQL
transformation graph looks like and here
I can go here so I have some like
Upstream raw data and then I have some
staging
um tables and then I have my customers
and Order Stables that I'm defined that
I've defined here
so this is all cool and you know it's
great but like we we asked this question
it's like this tool is really awesome
super simple to use but what's in it for
us what's in it for the data scientists
and so
um as of DBT 1.3 there is actually
support for python models so instead of
defining your models in SQL you can also
Define your models in Python so and
that's why we come in so at file we're
building a python runtime for DBT so you
can attach your
profiles yaml so in this case duckdb
and I'm just configuring file as my
output and now with duckdb I can also
run python models so just to show an
example of that you know imagine it's
like year two of the jaffle shop our
e-commerce store and I want to now do
some fancier things uh like make a
forecast so if I rename this file
like that and then after my here's my
like python model which ingests from a
Upstream uh table and I can just refer
to it like this very simple and you know
there's some like profit of course uh to
like do a simple forecast and I have
some more Downstream Transformations
happening in uh SQL so this is like
after that python model and once I have
this like typical duck DB run would
actually fail but in this case I can
just run this and because I'm using file
um
it'll it'll python models
um in the middle of my Dag
oops
all right this had to happen right uh
but yeah just take my word for it that
it works
um
thank you thank you thank you
so that's it yeah give us a star here at
Foley I slash file
thank you burkai
next up we have Eric Walsh for graph
blast and network X
all right yeah but Cameron's first
obviously
yeah
while they try I'd like to brag about
something today we had core duels
um in Radio City just uh before this
around 2 45 2 15 I think uh Thomas and I
went head-to-head it was an intense
battle we choose the hardest uh type
type cheer hardest tier of question and
we actually Drew so yeah ladies and
gentlemen
you have someone who in front of you who
drew with Thomas so I guess tap one more
time for me
[Music]
appreciation I like it
all right cool Cameron
almost almost
not just a plotting tool all right all
of the images that you see here
were not made using Seabourn they were
not made using network X nothing else
and all of these plots were made between
last night and uh five seconds ago but
for those of you who don't know me my
name is Cameron Riddell I have helped
organize this conference taking care of
things for the Sprints taking care of
things for our Keynotes and all of the
fun behind the scenes stuff this is
actually my first in-person Pi data
conference so thank you so much for
having me here
thank you
all right what is the most basic thing
you can make in matplotlib well the
documentation always says it's sine and
cosine I think that's used every single
place in the documentation but that's
not my opinion matplotlib is not just a
plotting library right in my opinion the
most basic thing you can make
it's a circle right we have patches that
do that and what I can even do with the
circle well I can add a rectangle under
it and if I keep adding layers we end up
with a beautiful stick figure and that
plot lid is not just a plotting tool
I can make actual art with matplotlib so
my challenge to you all who use
matplotlib and you say import
matplotlib.pi plot as PLT and then as
soon as you see plt.plot doesn't give
you what you want you say oh no
matplotlib cannot do what I want yes it
can you just have to keep digging
matplotlib is very dense you need to dig
through and find out in order to
leverage all of the Power and all the
control it gives you
you can visualize networks Network X
uses matplotlib under the hood you can
even add animations crude animations to
your plots if I had more time this would
be a lot shinier but what you can see is
I just use four circles here to
represent different nodes I use lines
with a different line style and then I
update that line style in order to make
it appear like those lines are moving I
could even increase the size of the
recipient circles the child nodes and
there you have it a distribution or a
visualization of something like a load
distributor right matplotlib is not just
for plotting
you can even make tables these are
pretty hot on Twitter right now and I
think uh MPL tables is a brand new
package that somebody has made I did not
use MPL tables following my uh my
original preface Instead This is
actually one matplotlib figure with 15
different sets of axes that I all made
invisible I put a single text on each of
those axes right in the center and then
I created a I took off all of the spines
matpot lives not for plotting you can be
so creative with all the things that you
can do with matplotlib when you're free
from just a plotting API you're truly
only limited by your creativity
a heat map is something that is very
widely used in order to represent some
2D data commonly right people use these
direct correlation Maps obviously
there's not a correlational matrix
because it's not square and also there's
no main diagonal but if this were a
correlation Matrix whenever I see a heat
map like this my eyes glaze over just a
little bit because I have no idea what
you want me to look at instead we can
use tricks like redundant signal
encoding in order to convey stronger
messages I am encoding the strength in
both color and size and now you can very
easily tell oh which ones do I not care
about which ones do I care about you can
use this in statistics instead of
redundantly encoding the same signal you
can encode the size as a p-value right
instead of just the strength of the the
resulting R of your piercing correlation
and that flatland is not just a plotting
tool everything that you saw here today
was done in matplotlib and I hope
there's a surprise because this is not a
slideshow this is not PowerPoint this is
not Google Slides this is matplotlib
that is just waiting for me to enter key
presses and every time I press a button
it goes to the next slide so please
nobody asked me to go backwards because
I cannot do that
[Applause]
thank you everyone my name is Cameron
Riddell you can follow me on Twitter at
Riddle Me Cam I post dataviz all the
time and I absolutely love matplotlib
and hope to see you all more
foreign
this is all the code that I wrote 272
lines between last night today you can
see my slides are broken up into my main
slides my wrap up slides there and they
are all just functions that operate on
the one figure that I created at the
beginning of my program
that's awesome
now it really is
um also did you guys know Cameron lost
to Thomas
you're just saying
but to be fair when I did draw against
Thomas then Cameron was coaching me and
three other people but we were a good
team
um right now we have Eric Welch for
graph blast and network X
[Applause]
hi there I have a lot of talks so no
introductions I'm going to talk to you
about graph loss and network acts uh my
five second Pitch is if you've ever
wanted Network X to be faster uh come
check out what we're doing with rap loss
I work at in video on the Rapids project
uh so you may be familiar with some of
the uh letters in this the blast looks
familiar
um so from the 70s from basic linear
algebra sub programs that's how they
named things in the 70s uh so graph loss
must be that but for graphs it's newer
it's more modern and this uses an
equivalent that uh it's been known for a
long time that like sparse linear
algebra problem
is equivalent to graph problems and vice
versa Versa if you have the right
mathematics to make that equivalence and
this is often done with an adjacency
Matrix not always there are other
matrices and here we're doing a
one traversal step from node four to its
out edges to uh the neighboring nodes
one and three like we're just doing a
matrix multiply from the uh sparse a
with the sparse V
uh we also often think of the blast as
being fast like these are the kernels
that people wrote a long time ago that
like we don't need to think about
uh the same for graph loss it's a low
level so these are building blocks uh
for building kind of higher level uh
applications higher level algorithms uh
but I would it's also high level like
these let you think about how to express
things in the terms of linear algebra
um like there's a lot of low-level code
about how to uh properly run these on
Hardware that you should never like we
don't need to read that Fortran code or
like in graph law it's like it's very
complicated how they do the data
structures
um so here's a few examples in graph
loss of a few algorithms a single Source
shortest path
um it's pretty dense there's a lot of
syntax I can't go into detail uh but the
frontier here is a vector and the a is a
matrix and we're doing the python Matrix
multiply and we're changing with Matrix
multiply means instead of doing like the
normal like we're multiplying the
elements and adding them together with
the summation we're doing like uh Min
plus as opposed to plus times and we're
doing an accumulation back into front
here with the minimum of min uh for
parent BFS like we need to use masking
uh so masking in the operations is
essential for work efficiency
um
uh and now trying to connect the dots
with network X like what is Network X
it's on that uh slide there you all
probably know it's it's the uh most
common uh popular uh graphite library in
Python it's a I would describe it as a
great reference uh
of algorithms in Python uh so it's well
known it's popular like there's a lot of
algorithms it's very well documented
well tested and like it's nice to read
and it's great for small graphs
it's a big problem it was not meant for
large graphs so it's pretty slow
uh so I think we need a foundational
like sparse library that is fast
flexible scalable can run anywhere and
is able to handle a graph problems and
I'm going to throw down the gauntlets
and saying that sci-fi sparse is not
that Library
um no time to go into detail here like
yes there is the the side by Spar CS
graph we're doing graph uh you know
algorithms on Cyprus virus algorithms or
objects but it's fundamentally the wrong
object model it's the wrong API for
doing graph things even for algorithms
where
um
that is not for me
um it can do well like pagerank uh it's
a lot slower than state-of-the-art
algorithms like graph last can be 20
times faster or more than just on the
CPU on the GPU I'd expect it to be way
faster than that
um
and so yes I'm going to say graph loss
can be that foundational Library however
like it's hard to build a new
foundational Library it's hard to
connect to where the users are
and so what can we do let's work with
network X this is where the users are
and so coming to network X 3.0 the code
freeze was today this will be released
in a few days probably uh is dispatching
so we can uh introducing dispatching of
algorithms to different back ends from
the start we'll have the a graph loss
back end and a cool graph back end
um so graph loss algorithms is our
library that
um implements X API and we will be able
to run on like CPU soon GPU and after
that uh with desk
so this is our um like software volcano
uh I love Thomas coswell's um
from yesterday this has the imagery of
exploding out into the uh applications
and so I'm stuck in this software layer
but I think there's so many really cool
things that like the map social sciences
genomics disease propagation wonder why
uh that'll be relevant
um and even just like regular business
so
check it out
[Music]
cool is this this mic is working all
right uh next up we have David
charleswick how cold spins up a desk
cluster
David are you in the room
I'm not sure if you're David are you
David he's not all right
um if it's not we have intro to CAD CAD
all right come right up foreign
[Applause]
so we have Emmanuel for intro to CAD cat
and next up we have
inconsistent and incoherent Juan Luis
all right
me
called them inconsistent and incoherent
right so I was supposed to have a joke
for this time I guess
um which I don't so
anyone in the audience have a nice short
joke one-liner
good fun
did you hear the one about the broken
pencil no I
don't know
one more about time travel no
okay
yes
okay I think we can do a couple more
because this is taking a while
what's the difference between a scalar
and a vector
laughs
I think I would have to bring them
back nice all right I kind of think it
was the mosquito thing it kind of flew
over my head but we have Emmanuel
okay um
good afternoon everybody my name is
Emmanuel Lima and I'm going to talk to
you guys about cat cat a working in
progress modeling library for
generalized dynamical systems
so this is just a little bit about me I
am a research software engineer at block
science and I am the lead engineer for
for cat cat
so um first of all what is cat cat so
basically cat cat stands for complex
adaptative Dynamics computer aided
design and that is just a mouthful for
for saying that catch CAD is an open
source framework for generalized
dynamical system and what we are working
on right now the effort that is more
advanced here is our reference
implementation in Python but we are also
working on other implementations in
other languages such as Julia for
example
so basically what is a dynamical system
dynamical system is the the mathematical
representation of an observed phenomena
that has a certain state that is the
snapshot of the attributes of a system
and rules about the time evolution of
that system and that dynamical system
comes in various flavors like like for
example the the one that we have on this
equation here is a Time discrete
dynamical system
but then we went a step forward and now
we have generalized dynamical systems
that basically instead of having a
system that evolves basically a real
number or a set of real numbers now we
have a general generalized version of
that theory that deals with the evolving
of a generic data record and for example
that you can see on this uh type 3 Type
3 here
um the the data record can have any kind
of types that one may want so you do not
you are not stuck to floats basically
and so that was the first con this is
this is the first main concept of cat
cat so you can have the data records and
those data records we call spaces
and the second main concept in cadcat
and in GDs is the concept of a block so
basically the block is the main logic
that is going to say how the system is
going to evolve over time and those
blocks are those gray boxes on this
diagram here and you can see that we can
make them together join them according
to their domains and co-domains the the
colored circles and we can put them
together like Legos so you can make an
arbitrarily complex wiring of blocks or
rather wiring enough Logics to have a an
arbitrarily complex time evolution of a
system or of a generic data records
basically
and all of that uh goes back to those
three uh small Concepts here so the
first one is tearing so
um I can if I look at this diagram here
I can look at the whole diagram and just
look at it all as the same just one big
block or just one big logic or I can
tear this one big logic uh into their
small constituents there are those small
gray boxes and that's the process of
tearing and then there is the process of
zooming where I am concerned only with
internal logic of each of those gray
boxes and I want to model only the gray
boxes and the process of linking that is
the process of
joining each of those blocks together
because basically the output of one of
those blocks has to be the same as the
input of the next block so by doing that
I can make like arbitrarily long
pipelines or wire years of data
Transformations for those data records
that I just showed
so basically our main
motivation for doing catcad was systems
engineers and mechanism designers were
using like very expensive proprietary
software for modeling and we wanted to
have an open source alternative for it
and this is just a a little bit of the
syntax that one can use to make those
wires in cadcats so the space is a
decorator over a class that says a data
record the block is a decorator over
regular python functions that says the
logic of the time evolution of the
system and then you have some small
boilerplates to create the experiments
run the experiment and then you can
produce for example in this small
example this random walk that's just a
chaotic dynamical system
and this is just some pointers some
links in case you guys want to learn
more and in case you guys want to to
check out our progress we are at
github.com
thank you very much
all right so
inconsistent and incoherent Juan Luis is
here
I saw who won who wants to talk in uh I
data London
the the one about the pandas logos
do you know the story about the punish
logo now I do and I actually have a
survey
um that I want to do at the end so stick
around
um Okay so you can put a timer because
foreign
okay thank you very much
um I'm not supposed to talk a lot but
you can put the timer anyway because I
want to preface this by saying that
I went to make a talk that relies on a
weird display setup and audio on Linux
and his theme on Linux so everything can
go wrong absolutely everything if it
works it's gonna be a miracle
so allow me one moment to set up the
things
the HDMI one is active
so what about doing this is this gonna
work I have no idea what I'm doing
but I promise that it's worth it
oh thank you
uh nah it was the other way around right
now it's not gonna work so you're going
to see the whole thing so first thing
that doesn't work there we go
second thing this timer is incorrect
probably like four minutes now so let's
do that
third thing
yesterday it was said that we're too
serious in the python community
so I want to do something completely
different
that was a Monty Python joke in case you
didn't get it it's because you are too
young foreign
people you can watch Monty Python it's
good it's all but it's good
um okay can we
you don't hear that right oh yeah we
where's the
oh is it coming out of the laptop
can someone hold it I only have one hand
okay
[Music]
third thing that doesn't work HDMI audio
now let's try something else
[Music]
also kids the music is followed but it's
good
[Music]
oh my God
foreign
all right
[Music]
coherence
on your own
[Applause]
[Music]
um
is wrong
the minutes documentation
documentation
is wrong and his documentation
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
all right
um so now we have James Powell words I
may have made up and actually I just
have one joke that I actually thought
for today
yeah just for James
so what do you call it when James moves
from his
seat to the podium
nobody all right it's called Power
movement
[Laughter]
thank you
okay let's get this going you give me a
moment
okay I hope everybody is enjoying
themselves as we make it to the end of
the second day of piety in New York 2022
I know I have had a blast and I am now
beginning to remember why it is that I
came to these kind of things in the
first place this is my lightning talk it
is titled words I may have made up we're
up high data at New York City it is
Thursday November 10th 2022. I'm James
Powell if you like this you can follow
me on Twitter or not I mean I don't care
that much uh let's take a look
so it turns out I am so insufferable I
cannot stop making up new terms for
things that already exist for example
you may have heard me talk about the
nominal decomposition of a boundary
modality that sort of class method
basically is or pumping or priming a
co-routine where the subjectivity of
homogeneity that's what happens when you
stack or unstack a panda's data frame
sometimes I just repurpose or jumble up
words that already exist like when I
talk to people about the fundamental
ambiguity of in-band encodings that's
why we need to capitalize N64 and pandas
or that co-routines allow you to
lexically linearize control and data
flow so you can represent State machines
in a different formulation or that
there's exists in Python such thing as a
lowercase uppercase Cod routine Co
routine but that's not my fault that's
actually the fault of the pandas I mean
of the uh not the panda stock Edition
the python documentation because this is
what we used to call a co-routine with
the lowercase C but this is what the
documentation calls the co routine with
a Capital C the collection.abc.co
routine and so that would mean that this
would be a lowercase Co routine Capital
C Co routine it's not my fault it's
their fault for the documentation but
today we're going to talk about another
word that I believe I may have made up
the term is the restricted computation
domain here is the scenario real you are
using pure Python and you write a python
class represent some dot Hub not data
but.com some singular entity it has an X
and A Y it has two pieces of data
Associated within you create a
collection of these datum into one piece
of data and you compute some operation
on it for example the mean and when you
do that you say well you know what
everything seems to be so big I'm
running out of memory really quickly and
the reason for that is if you look at
the size of an integer python it's 24
bytes but hold on a second isn't this an
N64 so there's going to be eight bytes
in size where the other 16 bytes going
and if you think about it we would think
that a two integers would be about
double this 48 bytes and so a tuple of
one integer would be 48 bytes there's
some overhead with the two bullet and
Tuple of 200 just actually that's not so
bad I'm not seeing that much overhead
for just the Tuple itself but when you
take a look at your.com class and try
and figure out how big it is you'll see
that it's also 48 bytes but that seems
to be kind of strange because if I add a
lot more elements in it oh hold on a
second that's not measuring the size of
the entire data that's just measuring
the size of the collection and so in
order to actually model two integers I'm
paying 48 bytes plus the 48 bytes of the
original integer that is a lot of memory
that I'm spending to store basically 16
bytes worth of data and you say to
yourself there's gotta be a better way
than this
but one thing you already got wrong is
python images are not 64-bit integers
there is no such thing as an N64 and
python effect python integers
automatically promote this is why you
can take an integer and raise it to the
20th power or the 200th power or 2000
power or the 20 000 power they
automatically promote they have no fixed
size and in fact they're modeling
internally is very strange here's the
thing they're not two's complement
there's some weird sine magnitude
representation they're a c array of in
32 digits but you set all of that aside
and say you know what my solution is
I'll use slots because I've told it
slots makes everything better except
slots is actually pretty useless it
doesn't really help you in any real way
in fact they didn't even make this thing
smaller slots is marginally interesting
but slots means you're going down the
wrong path because it turns out that
even if you try your hardest you cannot
control memory loud and pure python
python does not give you the ability to
do that with the small exception of the
array module in Python which I don't
think anybody actually uses well it
turns out that what you're going to do
is you're going to say I'm going to
create a special manager class
represents the collection of all my data
a data set class and I'm going to
construct it by passing in my
individual.com and this is what the
code's going to look like originally and
then once you do that you're going to
say you know what's going to happen I'm
going to start absorbing more
functionality into this data set class
like the mean method I'll implement it
inside the class and so I'll call it
from the outside so instead of having
these operations that occur at the pure
python level I'm kind of pushing these
operations into the manager class the
data set is responsible for constructing
itself it's responsible for computing
the mean well that's basically what a
certain computation domain is it's the
idea of taking the code that you have
and instead of modeling the individual
entities of the pure python level you
create some sort of manager class that
models the entities themselves and it
turns out that when you do this you can
start doing things like dropping
mechanisms down to the C layer and
recovering your ability to exact memory
layout who cares about this well it
turns out that if you have a restricted
computation money if you have one of
these major classes you can do full
control over encoding a memory layout in
fact if you look at a numpy endearing
you'll see it as just the restricted
computation domain that allows you to
take a raw view of memory and add an
interpretive layer like the shape the
strides or the D type
this is why for example numpy India has
certain limitations because it's a raw
view of memory you can't grow it you
have to actually copy it over this is
why we say for example the list is fixed
shape and dynamic size and unplanned era
is dynamic shape and fixed size because
you can change the interpretation layer
and that's mostly free we like to say
that it's free like a glass of water in
a European restaurant you're still going
to pay for it but not a whole lot now it
turns out that when you have this numpy
Theory you can do some kind of tricks
with it like you can swap out the
interpretive layer so you can take
something that thinks that it contains
in 64s until it actually contains n32s
you can even see the endess of the
computer here you can see that it's
reinterpreting this data well it turns
out you can also do things like
eliminate Dynamic dispatch and data
dependencies for example
well
thank you
all right thank you James
cool uh so we actually had only 10 slots
for this lightning talk but people were
so interested that they put two extra
slots just by themselves uh so let's see
if those people are actually here one
more slot
okay we can do one more so sorry if
you're 12.
okay she only needs two to three minutes
and you are check Jen cool teaching data
science in Africa
[Applause]
but it works before
I hope it still works
it works on this computer before
okay we got it all right let's go okay
fine let's let's go let's go quick uh so
I'm just gonna tell you one thing but uh
I have teach their science in Africa in
parking Ghana so uh what is happening is
that uh we have Hubble data workshops so
what is humble data Workshop it's a
self-paced data science workshop for
absolute beginners so you know you have
a bunch of Jupiter notebook and people
can work on it by themselves they learn
from absolutely zero they like they have
never called one single line of python
previously in their life they're
absolute beginners but they can start
and then eventually they will go to like
some graphs with method lips so it's
really cool
um so what we also want to do is to kick
start a community by bringing mentors
and mentee together so uh that's why we
really want to have like people sit
together to work together uh so the men
her Mentor can build up some kind of
relationship like you know friendship
and you know they can also help each
other in the future
um also we try to get all the mentees uh
after they are finished they would
become mentors in the next event so they
would feel encouraged and empowered
because now they're teaching some other
people which like you know they also
understand what like people may get
tripped over before because they have
experienced that themselves before
so uh we started in 2020 uh by uh a few
friends or like a friends of mine also
we know each other because of Pi data we
sit together we create this uh all these
materials we have actually bring it
online before party the global is coming
well we're not doing Friday over this
year but we've done it before uh also
pack on us so we have bring it to 500
yes also online python Africa also
online uh you know Africa doing things
online is very challenging so uh but
since now the wire is open again we have
done it in person we have done a Euro
python which is kind of like the main
python conference in Europe and also I
I've just done it last month in Ghana
which is amazing see these pictures this
beautiful faces like people smiling and
so happy and like that that's the one on
the right hand side right the left-hand
side people are like working so hard you
know scratching their head and all the
mentors are really like trying to help
so that's really really good and so
things I've learned is that um
I I managed to make it happen because
there's a very amazing like local
organizing team there so they really
like helped me out a lot and you thought
like oh Ghana you know it's very far
place I don't know the local community
there but once you make a connection and
people there are really really like
willing to help
so also there's a lot of mentors they
are recruit by the local organizers and
they're all like very helpful they even
help them to like install the the the
environment the day before so we have uh
the install installation party it was a
big success actually it's a lifesaver
because people who hasn't been to the
party and come with a computer that
doesn't have a python running is really
challenging so uh we are really happy
and people are really like grateful and
like you know there's so many people
come back to me and like being so happy
is like oh thank you so much like we
really love this
so
um how I can help so uh for example if
you have any like local communities that
you have a bunch of people you want to
teach data science from scratch to them
so uh let us know so maybe we can like
see how we can have humble data at your
local community
um also uh all the materials are open
source you can go there you can update
it prove read it uh you know because I
I'm sure that like some of you sitting
here of her experience in data science
so you can help also if you speak other
languages I have a dream that like if we
can translate the virtual material in
Spanish we can bring it to Latin America
and wow I want to go there so or maybe
you need to come with me
um also organizing events so again if
you know the local community or you're
part of the local community if you want
to organize some more data let me know
and we'll see how we can work together
and also Financial sponsorship so my
trip to pikon Ghana I need to thank my
employer Anaconda so it's like they
support me and help me to be there we
also sponsor some of the uh attendee as
well to attend the conference attend the
workshop so really thankful for them so
if your employer also want to like you
know help to spread data science you
know talk to me and see how we can work
together so uh that's it uh from this
talk thank you so much